lawfare on the South China Sea conflict
is the name of this panel and I think
the organizers may have had
so for Thought thinking about law fair
not just legal issues just as yesterdays
panels talked about the sweep of history
which is vast and the sweep of
geopolitics which is also equally vast
so please take my comments today in the
context of a view that says that a legal
approach alone is insufficient for
dealing with these issues and also
dispute management mechanisms as
important as they are is important as
the rule of law is are insufficient as
well they need to be set in a broader
context my particular work delves into
US policy so I unapologetically take a
view that tries to provide an
independent assessment an unofficial
assessment of US policy and let me make
three broad points in my comments this
morning the first one is that from a US
policy perspective China has been in
remains the main source of instability
in the South China Sea and this has been
unavoidable to some extent by dint of
geography and China's rise so no blame
on China but just because China is big
in there if there's history and things
are happening very rapidly that's part
of it but also a lot of it is much more
active policy intention coming out of
Beijing's certainly since 2010 spurred
in part by the international legal
processes that we talked about the note
pro ball in 2009 and all of the
catalysts that that created in terms of
accelerating disputes and getting your
position as strong as possible in the
court of international law and opinion
was very important and that was
accelerating a more assertive China I've
written about this in a number of
reports including talking about China's
development of what I call tailored
coercion in to specific instances that
we saw highlighted yesterday one of them
was when Carl Thayer talked about the HD
981 oil rig and using the 8200 ships
around that oil rig in disputed waters
that was coercive Taylor coercion from
my perspective in terms of pulling
you're putting pushing your weight
around your little brothers
in trying to push your way to your
position and make it clear who's in
charge the Scarborough Shoal incident as
well in 2012 notwithstanding the fact
that yes the Philippines went in first
to stop the poachers you know the fact
is that at the end of that crisis China
came away with de facto control over
scarborough shoal and hat and haven't
relinquish it and that's what
precipitated this arbitration case known
as Philippines the China um more
recently though as Australian friends of
mine Rory Medcalf and Ashley Townsend
have just put out on a very very good
report out of the Lowy Institute in
Sydney this month called passive
assertiveness they argue that China's
actually tried to lower the temperature
on some of the tensions that have arisen
from that initial sort of rush in to
determine whose whose claims are real
and who has influence and I think they
have a very strong argument to make
except I don't know how passive creating
thirty-two hundred acres of new land in
the South China Sea is it doesn't seem
that passive to me and the enormous
environmental damage the sort of faux
fortification movements by China in
terms of dual-use infrastructure being
built in taking ships and aircraft in
and out you know it makes it not that
passive but nonetheless maybe more
passive than the original post 2010
assertiveness so again from the United
States perspective China seen as the
main source now we can talk about a time
on history and where do you want to
start the history absolutely if you
start on a different date and a
different year somebody else is the
problem this is this is by no means
saying China is the only source of
instability this is no means by saying
that China's rapid rise in and of itself
is a bad thing in most ways it's a good
thing but nonetheless China's growing
dependence on global resources and trade
have led it to
it's see word reaches into an open ocean
Navy as well and there are many
reactions to China's words and deeds
that have raised tensions in China
prefers to point the blame on those who
are calling out China and reacting to
China but China also needs to understand
its actions are what precipitated those
those responses in the first place and
that's why I made the point yesterday
that much of what is happening can be
explained in broad international ations
theory in terms of balancing against a
perceived growing threat in threatening
power and this is complicated because
China is not just a challenge and even
less a threat it's as much of a partner
as was mentioned yesterday in the
international system the economy global
issues and so on so it makes it very
very complicated to deal with
unfortunately there's an enormous
pessimism in Washington on both sides of
the aisle about the next
administration's policy toward China I
have to be honest I've had too many
meetings and too many discussions with
too many people to tell you that China
specialists and Asian policy specialist
in more general foreign security policy
specialist in Washington believe pretty
strongly that we're heading toward a
period of intensified competition with
China in the next administration almost
regardless of what the u.s. months to do
and the south china sea remains litmus
test for much of that for better were so
this is a very important issue at the
very least and it's very important to
have dispassionate expert scholars you
know who are able to talk about these
issues and in talk about because we're
going to have uncross be a big issue in
terms of the 200 nautical mile e eez
surveillance question that will come up
again repeatedly in the next
administration but also issues about the
u.s. philippine alliance and the u.s.
outreach to vietnam and more generally
to Southeast Asia and the President of
the United States is about to take of
course very important his first trip to
Vietnam and he has some big
announcements I think to make as he
heads out there and will be hosting the
deputy national security adviser later
this month in Washington to talk about
some of those let me turn quickly to the
very important short-term challenge
though the arbitration ruling because
before we get to the next administration
this arbitration ruling is going to be
the weathervane of what where we'll be
headed beginning of the next
administration next January so the
international tribunal on the law the
sea under the permanent Court of
Arbitration of The Hague it's going to
issue a ruling any day but presumably by
the end of next month precipitated by
the 2012 Scarborough Shoal incident and
there are 15 claims that fall into three
categories and you can read this online
at our website it's called reefs rocks
in the rule of law by my colleagues mera
pooper and Harry crazy on my Asia team
where they've tried to provide a very
objective crisps extinct apologies to
the international legal scholars because
it doesn't have all of the footnotes of
all the legal documents but it really
tries to distill down what are the basic
issues here and they find that they fall
into three categories of terms of the
Philippine case the nine-dash line the
status of features and entitlements and
then China's activities in the
Philippine easy on the nine-dash line
when in 2009 China submitted that map to
the UN Commission on the limits of the
continental shelf Chinese statements
since then have often suggested that
China claims all of the territory inside
the nine-dash line but they've never
clarified the status of the features
whether they're reefs rocks or islands
and perhaps claiming perhaps territories
plus maritime entitlements we heard from
bill hatin yesterday maybe a third
element of that in terms of fishing
jurisdiction that's where the ambiguity
continues to to happen and that's not
going to be settled even after this
arbitration case unfortunately but
that's one of the big areas of ambiguity
that is related to the nine-dash line
claim the status of features and
entitlements the second area a category
of the arbitration case basically breaks
down the fact that these not islands
have we're talking about is what really
what we're talking but so when we talk
about islands we're wrong already in the
philippine case according the
philippines for the features
China occupies in the Spratly suvi Gavin
Hughes and mischief reefs are submerged
at high tide making them reefs or low
tide elevations and therefore not
entitled to maritime rights and
according to Manila four of the features
China occupies fiery cross reef Johnson
South reef quarters and reef as well the
Scarborough Shoal are rocks but not
islands and therefore only permitted at
12 nautical mile territorial sea
entitlement but no eez or continental
shelf there are huge questions about
Taiwan's sort of e to ABBA typing Island
i'll be at the inauguration in a couple
weeks be very interesting to see where
the new incoming president taiwan takes
her position after the arbitration a
very very important test for her
leadership and then their questions
about china's activities in the
philippine eez anyway there are lots of
implications of these that we've already
heard in the last two days and this
morning but other claimants possibly
joining the legal process China possibly
moving closer to declaring an air
defense identification zone to establish
administrative authority as they did in
East China Sea China may eventually or
is going to produce in could talk about
this i'm sure the basic maritime law
that we're expecting where the china's
trying to clarify and write in the
international legal sort of
understanding because there is clearly a
gap between our understanding of
international on china's perception of
it but even within China there are many
many questions about in disputes and
arguments and and and it's an ongoing
area of research the Association of
Southeast Asian Nations ASEAN will be
challenged code of conduct seems less
likely not more likely right now in us
through freedom of navigation operations
legal papers out of the State Department
called the limits of the sea papers
another dialogue on the rule of law can
all advance these issues but i think the
guideposts for the next administration
are going to have to be broader broader
still and I want to talk in my third
element here if I have it about the five
the five elements of the next u.s.
strategy for the South China Sea
apologies here and this is something I
wrote recently the diplomat but it's
also part of a two papers i'll be
publishing shortly one of them is on the
next administration's policy in the
Southeast Asia that will be out in a
week or so and then later by the summer
a paper on the South China Sea for the
next administration but five guide posts
that need to guide us strategy that are
broader than the legal issues broader
than the dispute management and
understand that the South China Sea
represents only part of a larger u.s.
strategy towards the asia-pacific region
the Obama administration's rebalance is
about allowing a broad balance of power
within the asia-pacific actors while
forging ahead with preserving and
expanding and inclusive rules based
architecture for international
interaction therefore the rebalance is
not and should not be interpreted as a
strategy to isolate China and indeed as
we heard yesterday from Harry the
administration has been interested in
more than asia-pacific it could not
ignore Isis in the Middle East
economical russia but i would add
couldn't ignore north korea putting
ignore iran there are a lot of major
issues the United States remains
interested in global security as well as
this rebalance to Asia Pacific I didn't
entirely agree with Harry's analysis
yesterday that essentially highlighted
only the problems of implementation of
rebalance policy I think I could to make
another case on the other side that the
administration has also done a lot of
things to implement the rebalance policy
not evenly not perfectly but there are
many things if you put the two sides
together they look a little different a
second thing that will shape the next
administration's strategy is the
bilateral relationship with China so
even before we get to the South China
Sea in other words I've already just
said the United States is worried about
global issues Asia strategy overall and
then the what is the relationship that
the united states will have with china
in the coming decade in the coming
decades that's a fundamental question
and without settling some kind of a set
of assumptions about that you're going
to be playing on this sort of sideshow
these tensions
we'll be playing out without
understanding where you're going with
China so the constant quest inside us
administrations is to create a strategic
partnership with China is some kind of
equilibrium with China some kind of
understanding modus vivendi with China a
new type of great power relationship is
one Chinese formulation would have it
out of Xi Jinping whatever whatever the
set of assumptions are there will be a
set of assumptions for the next
administration going and that will be
very important and I think here it's
just very important to remember that
even in the Pentagon at the Department
of Defense that a lot of the generals
and admirals who are often quoted even
making more provocative statements I
think Admiral Harry Harris and the Jane
perlas article of the new york times
today overstating the case that somehow
he's a provocateur that's again half the
story he's a provocateur when he talks
about pointed issues he's also an
amazing diplomat and could confirm this
room and and many others by talking
about the common interest that we have
there's a reason why Chinese are going
to be participating in RIMPAC and again
let me take exception with Harry's
statement yesterday he's right one can
make a case for not inviting China to
RIMPAC but I can make a case for
inviting China Turin pack and I have
made the case and those those cases are
this is the biannual region-wide
military naval exercise in the Pacific
in the United States invites countries
from the entire region to build
confidence to build understanding to
build a basic level of cooperation to
deal with the whole range of
contingencies that deal with disasters
in search and rescue and certainly no
we've seen in Asia in the last few years
with Malaysian airliner with natural
disaster no shortage of those very real
humanitarian crises and they're not
going to stop now that doesn't
necessarily mean we do RIMPAC to change
China's behavior or with the expectation
that China will now see our way and will
absolutely just agree with you as policy
that's not going to happen that's
unrealistic and it's not a reward to
China China takes a risk in
participating as well in these exercises
so it's partly making sure we have a
basic level of
channel communication with the Chinese
we need that to various means it can't
it's not just for impact we're impact is
one mean so yes RIMPAC can always be
expendable but there's another major
reason why the United States invites you
try not to RIMPAC and has nothing to do
with China per se it has to do with
everybody else in the region because in
the region especially in Southeast Asia
and the South trying to see claimant
states in particular you know if the
elephants fight or dance you know the
mice that mice get trampled and they
want to make sure can you know will the
United States be a responsible
stakeholder forget about China will with
the United States that's why I see on
was created was partly to maintain
outside major powers including China in
the United States and others to make
sure they didn't trample on Southeast
Asian interest directly because there is
a problem if so anyway there are a lot
of reasons to do this nonetheless China
opposes two salient challenges to US
national security interest from our
perspective pose a coercive threat to
regional order by exploiting law
enforcement and non-state actors low
threshold or limited violence capability
the so-called raised own situations in
order to expand China's influence at the
expense of its neighbors while avoiding
outright war that's the tailored
coercion even the passive assertiveness
that I referred to already that's from a
u.s. perspective we may not be right but
that's how we see it and we didn't just
make it up either if you go back to the
2010 Vietnam ASEAN Regional Forum we had
that a nice exchange about your big
power were small powers that's also
where Hillary Clinton then Secretary of
State stood up and kind of drew a long
line in the water and it kind of signal
a much stronger US position on the South
China Sea raising questions in China in
the region is the US changing its
position on a historic more neutral
position and in so very important time
to reflect on this sort of gray zone
situations instead of how thick can
China be allowed to cut the salami is
another way that sometimes put in terms
of these incremental cuts at growing
their influence like that oil
muscley nen to disputed waters building
these artificial constructs you know
these thirty two hundred acres out of
nothing so that's a concern another
problem that was also raised yesterday
by the general in particular but but
also by Karl fair the rapid military
modernization deployment of China's
capabilities a2/ad counter intervention
capabilities Cena's open challenge the
US military power projection forces that
help to underwrite a rules-based
regional order that is overlaid on these
historic legal very complex multilateral
multiplayer disputes so there's no doubt
this us-china dimension is huge when we
think about even the South China Sea for
the next administration let me go
quickly the other three points though
the third team is the critical role
played by continued US presence and
effective engagement with the region
many aspects of us strategy remain
focused on what the United States does
to retain its Ford military posture the
enhanced defense cooperation agreement
the Philippines for instance is a key
point a fourth theme is the strategy
must be comprehensive and therefore
extend beyond the tools available the
Defense Department largely the u.s.
goals are about the rules about trade
commerce freedom and that's where shame
fair I think from Harry let me know
endorse what he had to say us today
absolutely plays a role and economic
leverage is is critical for the United
States and then fifth and finally the US
policy must achieve greater clarity
about us interests even while u.s.
decision makers will necessarily wish to
retain flexibility over how to calibrate
its words indeed so these are some of
the guy posts that are going to try to
be used for developing a strategy for
the next administration in order to
create this inclusive rules-based order
around the South China Sea and around
the asia-pacific so I'm out of time
thank you very much
you